c'était comment des noëls d'autrefois
autrefois pas de grands repas de fête ni
de cadeaux sous le sapin même de
télévision nombreux étaient les français
qui allaient à la messe de minuit
alors pour s'occuper en attendant ce
moment fort de l'année les membres de la
famille se racontaient des histoires une
tradition aujourd'hui oubliée il y avait
des vieux comme un cadeau c'est une
tradition qui crée du lien social entre
générations tout en permettant à
certains grands parents d'en rajouter un
peu et vous croyez que c'est pas mon
conte de noël sa politique a tout de
même on a la côte d'ivoire pas celui là
ces histoires faisait le bonheur des
enfants excités à l'idée de pouvoir
veiller aussi longtemps durant cette
soirée magique
la vraie fête c'était compte d'abord
pour les enfants nous étions nous avions
le droit de veiller
rendez vous compte on veillait au tour
la cuisinière jusqu'à minuit et après
passé minuit
c'était la seule fois de l'année selon
les régions la veillée de noël se
dérouler soit en famille soit au sein
d'un groupe social plus élargie ainsi au
pays basque en 1968
ces bergers passer noël en entonnant des
chants traditionnels de noël en ce monde
répandent partout la même allégresse
comme le fils il ya 2000 ans la
naissance de l'enfant jésus
[Musique]
mais progressivement la messe de mini
perd de son importance alors plus besoin
de payer aussi longtemps certains
restent cependant nostalgiques de ce
noël d'autrefois un pilot pour ces
acteurs de théâtre qui en 1999 recréer
l'ambiance des anciennes veiller les
contes de noël à domicile
c'est la dernière invention de la troupe
des chercheurs d'art associe une veillée
qui démarre sur les chapeaux de roue
comme les ombres donné que du loup se
met à danser sur la neige aujourd'hui de
moins en moins de français vont à la
messe de noël
le repas est devenu le moment fort du
réveillon de noël
le temps du partage des légendes pendant
la longue veillée est bel et bien
révolue
[Musique]